hey everyone it's Mike bottles and
welcome to this presentation special
presentation an order flows trader with
NinjaTrader eight again this president
she's got nothing to do I've got no
association with ninja trader my
software runs on ninja trader and your
ninja trader eight version of order
foolish trader is available it's been
available but I don't actively push it
but it has been available I've had users
using it for since last year actually
and you know it's today I want to show
you this because me personally I'm
making that switch over to ninja trader
8 on a I'm on a permanent yeah on a
permanent basis you know my trading room
has been down this week would probably
be down the rest of this week so I've
taken this opportunity to spend the time
I spent about since since the European
open I've been messing around actively
really using it getting to know it
inside and out ninja trader 8 and I
think you should too if you're not
already using it now before I go any
further go through the disclaimer this
presentation is that for educational
informational purposes only should not
be considered a solicitation to buy or
sell a futures contract or make it any
other type of investment decision
futures train contain substantial risk
and is not for every investor and
investor could potentially lose all or
more than the initial investment risk
capital is money that could be lost
without jeopardizing lunch finance and
security or lifestyle only risk capital
should be as for training and only those
with sufficient risk capital should
consider trading past performance is not
necessarily indicative of future results
okay so let's take a look this is the
how the chart looks on ninjatrader 8 and
t8 the order flow chart ok and there's
some interesting things they got going
on here and you can have this thing they
call here the chart trader on the side
if you don't want it you just go up here
to properties you can take it out you
can turn it off and apply it's gone you
know for trading purposes you know you
probably want to have it on honestly I
wish I wish what I really wish I'm not
gonna get is I wish they had something
that you can adjust the maybe there is
not
where you can adjust what you want to
put in here
you know I don't necessarily care for by
it market buying the ass by on the bid
buying the bid sound you know selling
the ask I do like those but you know I
just wish you can sort of define what
you want to look up look at on here so
you know anyway this is the chart so you
go okay here just go over some of these
things here so like this one indicators
right if you want to add an indicator to
your NinjaTrader eight well assuming
you've already imported it's okay I'll
get to that in a minute you would click
on this thing that says indicators and
it looks like the old nt7 one you're
right they got the the standard you know
indicators like here I don't have
current opened a high a little close you
know if I want it I can just add it
there click apply and it'll come up you
know take awhile just gotta go through
all the data again but it's pretty
generally pretty quick time I can drink
my coffee but uh and of course it
doesn't working on there this huh a
little bit slow today I got a lot stuff
running on this PC at the moment I said
you know I'm not I'm just I'm in my own
beta testing mode ask your beta testing
I got a lot of stuff I'm working on
right now so I got a ton of stuff opened
up on this thing that's why it's a
little bit slow but again you know here
it is so you add it up you can see the
order flow footprint chart is the same
the numbers are all the same that's one
of the differences the big difference
between 97 and 98 is the way it handles
the data it's light years ahead and t8
is versus nt7 which is a good thing and
so when you reopen a chart the data is
the same Delta everything is the same
you know whatever indicators you had
earlier are still there doesn't it
doesn't disappear on you and start over
which is nice now
the big thing is okay with that with
that in mind yeah excuse me
I had this darn cold again and I'm
sitting here in the Philippines and it's
just killing me I lived in Singapore for
close to 10 years you know I wasn't as
sick now here it's every other month I'm
sick it's really because it's so hot and
I'm in and out you know they had taken
the kids to school and not so I'm an
air-conditioned car and into a building
you know outside in a 32 degree
temperature 35 degree temperature that
as it's just taken its toll on me but
anyway I digress I mean that's why I
sound like I kept getting the sniffles
again it's because of that it's the data
right okay you have to do a couple
things you have to save click the
enablement to save the data where is it
the wrong thing it's under tools so this
is your your main NinjaTrader
workspace right here okay what you do
you go to tools options news options
market data make sure is very important
make sure this show tick replay is
enabled there's a tick there right if
you don't have that enabled it won't
save the data properly okay once that's
done you you know when you have a chart
open they need to click properties of
the chart it's always good to check make
sure it's you know these charts are
saving it as well you know in from time
to time you should always you know check
it you know just as good practice that's
not it right here data series go here
tick replay make sure this is enabled as
well okay I mean doing it under the
tools it should be global but you know
sometimes these things you think you're
doing it and it's applying it to every
chart sometimes it doesn't you know like
here this is my bond chart go to the
properties or sorry the data series here
there see it sticks right so that way if
I reopen the chart or I open a new chart
you know all all the stuff should print
properly that's that's the big change in
what you call it in NinjaTrader eights
that a lot of people like you know
see see here I got the same indicators
you know the ratios are there the blue
colored ones are the nice ones
Delta scalper give me near the buy here
the buy here put a control trader you
know when pointer controls are in the
extremes up here up here this red one is
something else don't worry about that
stacked imbalances you could see it in
here you could actually go there this
thing up here just display it show what
you want to display now way to change
things like fonts so you want to make
them say you don't like the size of this
font right this is my template I'll just
open up the indicator and go inside and
manually change them you go here where
is it order flow straighter okay now
there's a couple things you got to
change right you got to change the font
here so you know same I'll make it
bigger let's make it 14 okay now you
also want you also have to change of
course is the font for this is for the
bottom part here I can I'm trying to
point out my screen but you can't see
it's this area down here so if you're
gonna make this say 14 you know you also
probably want to make this stuff here
you got to click here right this is the
thing you can't you don't click here you
click or the arrow is make that 14 as
well and the other thing is also the
imbalances okay volume and balance
because I can see imbalances here if you
don't if you just change the the regular
numbers or just you know these numbers
that I'll show you what I mean so I'll
click apply volume imbalance numbers are
the different numbers here as you see
house is the chart refreshes I didn't
change the volume invest that's why you
see it's a bit smaller here right
exciting change those you see here now
the Delta right that and that made it
bigger down here this is the summary
content which is down here and to change
the size of the imbalances I just go
down here volume imbalance of font and I
change it also to same size 14 you can
actually set it to 15 one one little
tick higher won't kill you
because it's an imbalance you know you
wanted to attract your eyes okay
so there so you see it's you know it's
bigger it's a little bit more readable
you know you could open up the chart you
click there and hold it you know you go
back and forth this is the imbalance
stack you have stacked imbalance here
you know right here 41:15 33 3 4 3 4 5
now you know one of the other things
that we've actually put in this software
I didn't put it in my programmer did and
he's like hey it's there for you is when
you get more than one imbalance one I
say not more than one when you get
multiple imbalances in a bar like you
know that aren't necessarily stacked on
each other like here you got on this one
again you know I you know what I have a
bigger size font size that's just the
bar chart here but you see it here right
you got 3 imbalances yes detective Allen
so you've got multiple imbalances so it
draws a box around it you know this is a
bond so there really wasn't that much
here you got three as well it's a nice
you know it's a nice little sign and
here you can see it this is the DAX
chart yeah here you got a shy shouldn't
sorry
I'll just make these bigger so you could
see it I should have prepared it a bit
more but again like I said you know I
saved my templates you know the the big
difference between sierracharts and
ninjatrader is Surak charts i go down
the rabbit hole change in my templates
and the whole thing's all messed up
completely and i got it later i got to
start over again NinjaTrader it's a bit
easier for me to recover if i make
mistakes on my my templates which you
know i I like that because sometimes I
get really creative at all and you know
you know you remember sierracharts they
offer so much things to put on a chart
that you know sometimes I start adding
stuff add and stop adding stuff that
I've by the time my charts done it's
like it looks
completely opposite of what I was
expecting and it's just a whole messed
up that I literally got to start over
again but you know NinjaTrader is a bit
better in that sense so here right
you got three imbalances here got
multiples here one two three one two
three these are not stacked imbalances
they're just multiple imbalances you
know in the same direction and it's
actually a nice little directional clue
on what the market is doing you know
it's nice to get them especially when
you know you see them with you know
other other indicators like like the
Delta scalper so you know you've got you
know strong negative Delta you got
multiple imbalances in the bar you got a
sell signal you know that that's what
you like to get you know signs like that
I mean it doesn't always appear but I
mean where they coincide but when they
do you know you can you know I know
people like to say all you got all these
imbalances got a ratio you've got you
know the Delta scalper oh you know they
just want to pile in so you know you got
you got a lot going on in this bar that
you know should be telling you to get
long so this is a delta scalp or giving
you a nice buy up here's a delta scalper
giving you a nice sell now the one
difference between ninja trader seven
and ninja trader eight is dealing with
the ratios it's a slight difference
you'll see here minus infinity when you
have a zero print on the bottom of a
green bar or if it was on a zero print
on the top of a red bar I don't know if
there was one here it would say infinity
it will say infinity I'm just just just
you know there's two different types of
zero prints right there's a zero here
because it's in the second spot but
it'll say infinity if it's right on the
the extreme of the bar on the top of a
red bar I don't think there was one here
this morning here's here's one sorry
infinity INF it's all zeros he had a
number something coming out at that time
so that that's it in case you're
wondering why it says INF then it stands
for infinity and you know that's why
that's why it does that we tried as we
might we couldn't get it to change but
you know anyways it's not the end of the
world
still you know it's still printing
blue-collar which again is what you
really want to be paying attention to so
you know the thing that's really been
frustrating for me though is setting up
the instruments it's being a ninja
trader sometimes you know some things
are very easy and sometimes things are
very hard instrumentalists it's kind of
nice you could have an instrument list
right here right if I want to open up
stuff you know Mike's is empty but you
know I use this one futures I've got all
my updated contracts in here and you
know you could just add them and there's
not it's not necessarily the easiest
thing but you know I'll show you how I
do it you know exercising I spent some
time trying to figure it out cuz you
know the way they said it works doesn't
really work I forgot what it is
instruments here okay no instrument
lists for example here okay so we'll do
this one Mike sorry these are all messed
up symbols Cl okay so here let's add
something we'll call it what do you want
to add button es okay here boom hey I
got es well you don't really have the
right es you know they're like well you
got a click on it I click on it I get
this expiry which is gray I can't click
on it I get exchanged default New York
Stock Exchange that's not the one that I
want I want to e-mini S&P okay so you
know it's like I got click here edit
edit cancel and it's add cancel so I
click on there add then I hit watch this
hit escape now that comes up the
instruments for me to add and then I
could just scroll down and find the es
here and boom there I got it I could I
could remove that right I could remove
CL TV I'll just show you another one
it's just one of those things huh I
don't I don't know how else to explain
it
let's let's pick another contract
something I don't have up work with me
people
what's a contract soy meal ZM join me I
like soy meal Z and well this this thing
isn't gonna do me any good I need the
one with the month on it
edit nothing again I get that same
stupid thing you know
edit no add okay close that down I get
this up so then I just type in ZM soy
meal futures there it's got this one I
don't want that one I actually want the
know if I want that well go these meals
a better contract to trade at this point
and that's it you know so yeah what I
can do now is well I should I want any I
should this is my main one so here at GM
I've wished that you would just pull it
up right but instead it pulls it up like
this which is kind of useless here whose
iam again it's just kind of frustrating
it's just something that you know it's
one of those things you're just clicking
around and then you get it then you find
its right okay so thanks for watching
this video you know to learn more about
order flows and how you could use it in
your trading or the Delta scalper be
sure to visit my website snort applause
calm and delta scalper dot-com so thanks
I hope you found this video a little bit
enlightening and if you're not on NT 8
you know think about making the switch
alright so thanks guys and have a great
day